[Music]
a lot of award shows have their own
caddy correspondent to comment on red
carpet fashions and say snide things
well the audiences are no exception
please welcome once again our own
audiences fashion assassin james
sinclair st wallins
okay okay
bring on my first fashion victim
oh
oh god look at you
you know that outfit really makes me
think it makes me think somewhere
there's the hobo walking around naked
next victim please
oh
the parade of sadness
continues look it's the beach boys math
teacher
aruba jamaica that shirt is why i hate
you
next
oh
mamma mia original broadway cast
my god that haircut makes you look like
a thelian rooster
cockadoodle don't
that's literally the worst thing i've
ever seen and i've seen tom arnold eat
buffalo wings with his shirt off
well i need to rest my voice so i'll
just silently judge you all till my eyes
throw up
you know i gotta tell you i really hate
that guy
but not as much as i hate
this guy
let's take a break